elle parle bien l'anglais l'esprit
maintenant c'est où un jeune homme est
allé de travail elle y travaille on va
voir comment tu parles on va faire une
interview my taylor is rich
[Musique]
on va commencer facile on va commencer
fascine
comment dit-on aux états unis hamburger
juste un burger bien
j'ai un peu comment dit-on vena chez moi
je ne suis pas une terroriste
l'irlande un autre touriste à nous de
gangsters lenovo
comment dit-on j'ai fait le loft en
france vous me reconnaissez agon show tv
une france dynamique dans le même bateau
mais rôle alaouite a fait des progrès
comment dit-on j'aimerais faire un
disque qui déchire sa mère avant le
doubs ne faut qu'une son choix qu boom
la date so fucking pas vraiment
comment dit-on je couche jamais le
premier soir à never give my pussy le
first knight
mais je suis cent vingt minutes
ah ah non mince sachant
comment
comment dit on en a en tout chez touché
ce sont des vrais comment tièche espoir
comment dit-on culio tu es l'homme de ma
vie
couillaud il de même
mal à ça la vie
attends je vais me tenir un peu
comment dit-on les skis ils vont en
faire une tête à paris en apprenant ça
on my god french people usman
leman dit on il va faire moins le malin
ardisson
à buisson dont play the game tonight et
comment dit-on cibafi ouvre sa gueule je
casse la tête
qui marche
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu